i just i just think that everybody
operates on a base level yeah
like you mentioned from where they are
and they're like if i can make this now
it's like it's like you know if uh
i don't know if i if i if it was the
rules were reversed between men and
women and men would marry rich older
women well i'm not going to marry a
woman that makes
fraction more than i do
i think men are hypergamous in looks
yeah
but what i mean is i'm talking if
there's some weird upside down bizarro
world of role reversal you know it's
crazy no women are actually harsher on
looks than men are now
i believe that yeah yeah yeah i think i
think i think men
the same way women want a man who's
their level and up in terms of economic
standing
men want a woman his level of
attractiveness or up
in terms of
that's not what i see because i see a
lot of like like
fat chicks with skinny dudes but today i
was in bentley center and i was asking i
was just asking my sister like how did
that happen but i think this couple i
think in regards to that though like
it's different him wanting that and him
being able to get it
if he had the options on the table yeah
right
well that's what i'm saying but i think
men are still like pickier or women are
still pickier than men even when it
comes to looks i think so yeah yeah yeah
yeah so even though they're hyper
pergamos it's just like the way the
dating market is now yeah men take what
they can get yeah
a lot of times
because you don't have that much option
so did you show them the chart um i
couldn't find it if you just google it
the kind of images
um but the thing is i mean it was a
gentleman i think on this show before he
says if you're in the desert and you're
starving you're going to take whatever
food they put in front of you yeah it
doesn't matter if it's some mashed up
meat or bugs or whatever because you're
starving you're in the desert um yeah
and so in in a sense and it's not for
some men certainly it's a sexual desert
out there and they literally are unable
to
i mean i don't know why
it's fine whatever um
so question for the girls
if a guy was in the one percent or let's
let's you know let's do top five percent
so now
and he wants to date you
but you have to share him
no i even say on the first date like
just be honest about the type of
relationship you want if you want
polygamy good luck to you it's not for
me if you want polyamory good luck to
you it's not for me i don't get mad at
that so would you rather have a guy that
makes less money and is monogamous to
you yeah okay
so let's actually i'm gonna up it one
percent this guy's multi-millionaire
you get you get the lifestyle so you get
cars nice house
and it's just casual so when he cheats
it's just
side chick
i like the thing is i get that yeah good
for him yeah but i wouldn't i wouldn't
you wouldn't do it no i wouldn't do it
no i can't yeah okay what
um
i'd like to believe that i could but no
it wouldn't work for me no no because it
is
it nelly
that's that musician you said maybe
yeah so i don't know i feel like his
wife knew from the job yeah about the
situation
but then obviously like finding out how
he does his dirt like without a condom
i'm like he could bring aids he could
bring gonorrhea or whatever then she's
like oh no but you know she accepts i'm
like i'm not here for the stress no oh
well i'm like what did you expect yeah
exactly
yeah so would you do it yeah would you
do it with rules that you agreed on no i
wouldn't do it
i have a high disgust factor i can't do
it yeah so
question what if you never found out
does it matter
it does matter no it does yeah it does
i could i would i would burn the house
down if i found out you had a child with
another woman so i would burn that okay
so question question vice versa do you
are you will you tell the person you
marry your body count
i don't have one are you a virgin yeah
oh good for
good for you i'm gonna
go good for you that's
[Laughter]
i don't think i've ever had a girl
virgin on the show
i know what about you guys yeah yeah you
want to tell him
um
if you wanted to know i guess so okay
because i always ask guys the same
question does her body count matter if
you never found out
yeah yeah it's not for me no it doesn't
it doesn't matter if you never find it
oh no no it matters
there was a time i used to simply say no
i'll be fine no it matters because
the bonding thing that you even talk
it's also the history of the person if
you want to combine your life that
person you need to know their history no
but i mean you knowing the body count
why does that matter that's part of
their history
that's part of their history crazy like
furry
it's part of the history i can't like
can i just intervene here yeah i feel
like it's kind of like
buying a car not knowing the image
or the msd history so like it might have
been like fixed up and everything but at
least you need to know the tangible
evidence just for you to make a decision
based on whether you want it or not
because it could affect pair bonding
some women just like have issues with
that later on in their marriage because
they've had a high
body count so for you it's it's for your
benefit to know so i have a how old did
you say you are 27. well that's that's
very impressive for one
have you found that dating is it hard as
a virgin
yeah yeah what what challenges do you
find they like to try and find like
their limits like what they can do
okay
and then so they'll they'll keep like
pushing you push it like let's try this
no let's try that yeah yeah yeah because
you know i've seen a lot of like very
very pretty virgins that are in the
church that have the same problems and
it seems like it's tough because
like those guys
don't want to wait for a virgin when
they can have the next girl for free
have you found that or no yeah yeah okay
because
i can ask you a question
would you
you meet a guy that you really like
etc he's dating you he's happy to wait
with you
would you
be
open
for him to be having sex elsewhere until
you get married no
so you want him to be again discussed
factor i'm not here for it i'm i'm from
zimbabwe i came here when i was 14. so i
grew up on like when you watch an advert
there's like an ads aids
campaign video something like oh you
have to get your partner tested so it's
like ingrained in me like i'm not here
for that i don't want to like
ask you can you go to the clinic and get
checked as long as i'm not here for that
let's say you like him and you trust him
right you trust his word so if he says
okay like i'll always use protection i'd
never put you at risk right
but obviously
understand it's amazing that you know
you've done that for yourself but
obviously the average person that we
live in very different times right now
that's why i won't ask him to do
something in this level that i can't do
like to me it's like a self-control
problem
for him
yeah
it's a heart it's a very hard sell i
think i know that's why it's difficult
because it's like saying because i think
it's like if he knows he's a like to be
with you he has to go vegan
yeah but